- It says product of Thailand.
- I think this is a Japanese treat.
That's why I've had them
since I was a little kid,
'cause I'm Japanese.
- But I thought they were Chinese because
I've had them since I was a little kid.
- Well you've been lied
to your whole life.
(funky music)
- Pocky! Love it!
- I didn't know what
they were called either
when you just said Pocky I was like--
- How do you spell that again?
- My mom was feeding me Pocky
from the umbilical cord.
That's how long I've
been eating Pocky for.
- I just love Pocky as a snack because
it's not too sweet and not messy.
And you can just (makes crunching noise).
- Stick is truly the best shape for snack.
- Yeah.
- Variety is the spice of life,
and today I'm excited to see
what you have to throw at me.
- But nothing will beat
chocolate flavored Pocky.
(funky music)
- Oh! Cookies and cream, oh shit!
- Okay, this might beat chocolate.
- I love cookies and cream ice cream.
- It taste just like the
cookies and cream Hershey bar.
- Mhmm, Mhmm. But wrapped
around a wooden stick.
- It's very standard.
This is a standard Pocky.
- It's a Pocky plus my favorite flavor.
I think it's great.
- Oh, they're nice.
- I thought this was good as a novelty,
but I would rather have normal Pocky.
Looks pretty though.
- I can't finish the stick.
- It doesn't really turn me on.
- I'm glad it doesn't.
(funky music)
- Ooh, it has a great, great scent.
Like it really does smell like green tea.
- Looks like slime on a stick.
- I love matcha.
- Ooh, that is a strong matcha flavor.
- Mhmm.
- Yeah, it's great.
- That's perfect.
- Does green tea have seaweed in it?
- Yeah, this tastes a little grassy.
- I like green tea better
than the cookies and cream.
- Yeah, ten pockys outta pockys.
- Pocky is batting a
hundred percent right now.
This is great.
(funky music)
- That smells like a fresh
grove of strawberries.
- It smells like that
gum that looks like tape.
- This smells like the medicine you take
when you're sick and you're a kid.
- Ugh.
- I'm so happy.
- That's great.
- I'm down for this one.
- Yeah. I could eat these, too.
- How often do you get to say,
oh, I really just had a moment today.
And that's what this is giving me.
- It tastes like dried
strawberries and cereal.
- Mhmm, I like it.
(laughing)
- Stop it.
(funky music)
- Chocolate banana, banana cream covered
chocolate biscuit sticks.
That's way too many--
- You're a chocolate biscuit stick.
(laughing)
- I love chocolate banana
- Wow.
- It's my favorite.
- Look how yellow it is!
- I would've liked it to be drizzled
with chocolate like it is on the packet.
- A fair point.
- Where's the chocolate, this is banana.
- Every time I have
banana flavored things,
I'm like what a weird flavor.
Then I take another bite and I'm like,
it draws me in.
- This is probably the worst
Pocky flavor of all existence.
(happy music)
- I'm down for Pocky.
Shout out to all the kids that
share their pockys on the school yard.
- I like the original
pocky the best, I think.
- Matcha is hands down
the best flavor of Pocky,
but that's not surprising because
matcha is the best flavor of anything.
- True. This is true.
- I think this was a great experience.
I enjoyed every single one of them.
I'd buy them all again.
They were all a delight.
(wooshing)